[Music]
[Applause]
and
[Music]
a single bone x although unsuitable watch at the
lease of 5 liters develops
apic the management and isles always
address him to collective expired the
rating also have a weekend pack in
audience by  auspices forumers first
and nilsson too much fax and the shin beth
din km forum and the stakes of this hole 16
at the project leader forum or at woking
everyday inderkum useless in origin the
critical analysis of the sports league heap
of slowdown trash to  this
stadium éloi et soc trang i believe in the
world has lost a great arena even
unusual like you machine to lose
what sum all the cloud
my dear friends if we want to be
effective or peace we must
attract convinced of our actions and our
commitments
then at work she tries to the
main pastor with marie mosser in laon in
the
aisne leggings
[applause]
mr president my guts ladies
and gentlemen heads of state and
government  ernally ladies and gentlemen my
dear friends i am honored and
deeply moved to be with you at
the peace forum in this week of
commemoration this year we mark
30 years since the fall of the berlin wall
and the opening of the iron curtain
thirty  years since the victory of
the solidarity movement in warsaw or the
velvet revolution in prague
thirty years since the human chain
of independence from vilnius to riga
and tallinn
and of course we mark this week
the end of the fratricidal fighting of the
first world war
this war this human tragedy
imposes on all of us the obligation never to
forget never to forget
the worst that humanity can produce in order to be
able to build together a
better future future it is this duty of
memory and action that  meeting
today but i would also like to talk
about another anniversary
7 170 years ago here in paris that
victor victor hugo opens
the peace congress that day he p  arle of a Europe
of the head and I quote the continent
instead of being a battlefield
it would be a workshop where we would have
before our eyes
the hope the joy and the effort of all
towards the common well-being
end of  citation ladies and gentleman and
structures many lives tout match
strong price victor hugo the world to be cloud
ready seem mysterious today we see
from the skies la dispo or we see you run
can make a diu nights this line
to the internationals of france
free entry
john inch only  from the thing market to
the rule of law
we shall never get off aof come and why
you labazuy situait à 0
because not only de yanbian sokouri
giada course this is that most a
spokesperson on because we expect every
member to have a junior
all this debate  must look at
azumi from al chemist below
mine demands for you explain the wall to
day one drop hot contribute to tackle
challenge justin and put your climate
challenge digitalization demography my
way chocol  ate poverty and we think
6 they actually have me all the
existing cooperation roles not going
down your going to the news by zaïm me
gilles ouimet jean like his
indefinite period of force thebaux unavailable
chef's life
we all have to contribute president of the
next up in common rail band giuly
geopolitics at commissions highland
games of how to world locking popping
unit eiu which collective the different
dyson organs like nintendo world my
business review which he hopes to we
come sail d'ozoir divided and yorda bring
together dollars by des  primes times and
you drop building responsibility for
miles from my friends and from so
gone and responsible road to howl
planet
good governance fight against au match
a noise spect photographer louie spect
false to say we are there
pippa did it anyway the police
told us  thomas fersen hot the president of
readers
yu ping as fails haiwan thun chl
battler been you need is willing to
whic  h you lie geopolitics of wydad
thing from end we speak here everything tried
to development corporation from
humanitarian aid to security intercom
an annex langton bajaus want to spend
more outside actions doubts
or bills i was used to fly to be
free from theron and  ugly have list of
what you see is it to have women in
uniform him to be this lord byron
what you see is it to day and women to
finish then civil grids
we hope to doloow corruption and we need
you are we need you  had the state of
government and loss in the national
organization for this is the only way to
peace
ladies and gentleman your challenge
jean arino me batte et 19 first time in
his three challenger have been turned
into opportunities for you go with women
and men broc dans  world's women and
together for freedom simply for a better
life stand in to gaza boots and
united use of course
the challenger sweetface studio different
no need for speed
denis to stand  together in the hands and
ever the swell not because a sheet
sap 13-13 dodge challenger in frame tube
of the we have the strike to fight part
by action at 0 in league 1
can we fight climate change and invest
in progress
can we stand  for peace and prosperity
of air france rio paris
it may well indicate a title
[Applause]
the chicks in china so Mr. wang
qishan vice president of the people's republic
of china will now take
the floor
[Applause]
it is first the  guitar
it's people false titles to believe
look for yann's golf at 6.3 liters
every time you don't have a title to those
of a brand let's not fall comedy franco did
not find the pilots on foot against 8
to  10 euros here in illberg average in
your ass look rigid or say chick yes
if china cheng obliged citizens of
its southern district is said to be scared
when I say driver ya calamity in
the false gods contain click in
china boilers puente  putsch
and links by chance I
dropped as many 0 notch but in front of
neighboring italy kong de macau
it didn't
tickle me I read hutin bankruptcy lortie this
disc of red qiaojia sounds better
off dumpsters when you cook
whose hemingway holds leftists  are
there rents that will prevent lots keep
warm three layers tchache antaya
nipples milk quotas
the idea that we bring back from samantha not
as a must see your hands up wyrwa y
make it felt in the congo by
peasant family hold on to the paito dalits
there is no like I took refuge min in
bed I like myself pierrât croco chemistry
charchar creusot and you say you nien
hsing watan from the Togolese sky
frenchy rails of manshia mine all this
if you activate in caen in the book of
cindy gouaille chorbane  china headquarters brand
new brand new the thousand heads
won't fall in the immediate future just
for the phantom band chan kin ball
fotolog cornaille knew of his own claude
lebanese champion a tango shin taï 80
like a brother in mein kamp  f and in 6 g
soon and romane shiva de biche yvan times
in the discontent in hordain
skull in the cra du niger and that of the
tiguan to be happy if van der sande
python boylan gave themselves the romaine
tutiaux faca might at the khroub in thierry
bouillet choice of a framework agreement areva
judge in orleans time in the fall of 6
2 against sochaux time too much but they
hold michiko american tries yengo
may chico maïga go will be support holds
only to cargo like the villain baugé
grimm fragile acquired in the  father arms
your mocking mi amor limits he never
a year
eiffage the cl de berat congo has changed
at your house you I played in grace at our house
the dogs mulched in the intro dean tai
shan you will have to go to lignières dear
no longer maintains  big at a handsome
too much foot in the match between iyh a congress
trails coaching cargo dear vadalle
self on six schools darling
after a quarter and sticks to researchers
not often living a michel thiollière
mondial michel jarraud de g  amme if it
will be necessary in the end to maintain if he stumbles
xinchun pick chichin he changes his mind
well
dalli
price that they would change good looks of
diane goyette apart from the relay place
chouhada country john key at roma jean
generation your boyer 1  giga end when we
look on food if the adq au tricot
tomkins ciel qui igo load off my
job tianjin de kwacha for the mirror
dated and very heavy tea party of the ump
fo michel holds this revenge to
fight on luigi early for  shout gare
de l'est here at torino noon sky
blue sky will fall minto and daf factory
long taxes his grieving fans
live eagle el hijo min rhodia book
by alice lerois i quote paulo cantor
of had a project that  she does not imagine at the
calm team in monaco beitenu shopping
mode of minimal rates and 110 leans me
on the water for our hygiene of a
family whose lé or la rue pine mike
adams
otherwise how the world sometimes touching
a time of  cottages sort but cindy
awesome king at paco t  umbereaux tanner
the chessboard choi
we are very well I roll iqwind to 13
women as long as a product that we are there
kang tearing up here like japan honda
crémant gym jean gay tonghua I
support tap hold I don't chat
geoffroy cannes suits early cotis at
south
why  red like lyon of a roger nsingi
will win the mfa holds after the
cold shower and roudil knew how to defend at
jeanine divine bakayoko mali from switch
fall authier I'm far crdp will
buy there is something else to return
to makeshift camps that of
chinese shoes ding aux  Areva pros flip-flops
above while a cost of a horse
cart found there at home without a
steward's role life in the dam at the maximum there
are hands on others or are slow in
size designating themselves we are therefore
intoning weigh  lighthouse gets big
boss done there is a big of the judges in
denial these worse at the combo druye
sichuan -j congoone siro pro3 will win some
in vg at maier mallet au chesnay
too nice don't bother louse  r other
boss dogs three diamonds
o2 at the coach and 6 in lyon b it's jules
verne chais de château tangorre I'd
[ __ ] the course hugo 10:08 am in early
codienne there the condron mines who hold
Thursday to cries then cheated hantsch
against we go to the  cref a skillet if
n'diaye town hall of sedières tango banshee
conches contains aware of 100 hp
din quan sows don diegue recent
kushchenko like jean taris return
kunda if I rubbed shoulders with rich he is a
robot and resin of a quad is here
jodar contain like  deacon friend jean
paul in 13 years i received ten soldiers
against ontario djibril tall in the eu
between title i'll answer will operate kouadio
which we owe indian tridon and
italy water
you talk about a notch here is close  sodial
protocol at the bottom of quarter jeans
and in yen champagne all went to
sultan hachim of white water jay coja
tombois fads of little and habib sy there is
no king i read ultra faurecia factories
announcement barter  missing-eyed
hums l  the issue of tianshan are
returned to the jo in the sky during well
received by roccoli min 7 or limagne
yung shing to dogs
paris militates at dassault because shindo where
everything is a good idea close to heart audrey
knows him and in brooch debit rooney or
having too little  thierry city awake a
cause of a delicious game while
insulting
good but until then he holds genius london
holds charles lynch the uk where to find
louis cha cha rumba guys india
jacqueline cruise robyn
carr plate and in 2003 if the
level girlfriend  bac exchanged thatcher july
and rare friendly cities condom feeder
to the media this tome held ig to him to a
little joy tropez in the flesh and in libya
kim kwan pump almost
unleashed bulls hulot speaks said jan van chi of
human lice at drian
[Applause  ]
but this film x tshisekedi president
sir felix tshisekedi president of
the democratic republic of congo will
now speak
and
sir emmanuel macron presides  nt of the
French Republic
ladies and gentlemen Heads of State
and Government Mr President
of the Paris Forum for Peace ladies
and gentlemen
Mr President the
French Republic thank you for having
associated me with this laudable initiative which
will  help to have to seize
the opportunity to exchange on the ways and
means of establishing a lasting peace in
the world
we are today confronted
with one of the greatest challenges of our
time that of gaining peace to
keep it  and to pass it on to
future generations to win this
peace each man each state must
question its contribution to
providing solutions to the challenges that
threaten humanity our
common heritage because peace is not
only the silence of arms but
it is also the contribution of answers to the
problems related to the youth to the famine
to the climate change and to the
health problems like the
virus epidemics to preserve the peace we  we must
share with others
engage in a debate on the solutions
mentioned by each other
so it is possible to have a common agenda
integrating a certain number of
cross-cutting values and giving people and t
e planet the primacy of our effor
s  we are indeed in front of
a major challenge which cannot suffer
from any negligence from any red
herrings and I would add from any
superficial solutions
the wars the conflicts the terrorism
in the world and the security must
stop it is enough to want it  together
and we will succeed
because it is our
common responsibility and history will judge us
I would be tempted to propose a
real global coalition for the
restoration of peace by dedicating it
necessary for the development of the
world
ladies and gentlemen point is not  need
to remind this august assembly
no continent is spared
by insecurity
you will agree with me that I
will not do in five minutes
come back to the case of each continent this
is why i would like to focus
on africa and the
democratic republic of congo
my country today africa more than
all the other continents is shaken
by conflicts of wars and by
terrorism  less than 10 years ago
west africa knew peace
and had equipped itself through ecowas
with a security tool for deterrence
and prevention of any conflict
today unfortunately we
deplore
the terrorism of boko haram
east africa is not spared either the
shebab terrorists sow death and
desolation
central africa is also experiencing
conflicts in chad in the central africa in south
sudan the democratic republic of
congo
located at the crossroads of several
communities under  regional can be
considered as the country which has paid
the highest price
the efforts have been made for the
pacification of the country is today
only five provinces thanks to the
forces of  e the army armed forces of the
democratic republic of the congo and the
collaboration of monusco are still
struck by insecurity while being
convinced of the effectiveness of the
military solution,
I think that
a whole program of  sensitization of the
populations and dialogue between the
different communities
the military solution is essential to
fight the armed groups certainly but
in addition to that it is necessary to answer the
problems of the youth who need
more supervision more democracy
and employment  africa in general
with its geostrategic position, its
young population and its
natural resources must stop being a
problem for the world but rather
become an important link in the
solution to the problems of the world
ladies and gentlemen to return to the
case of my country I  would like here to salute
the bravery of our people who have suffered
in their flesh
and on their soil a condensed version of horror due
to the absence of peace, but my  Despite this,
his strength of resilience and his
attachment to the values of peace have remai
ed intact, which is wh
we have engaged him in a fie
ce fight against anti-values
the democratic republic of the cong
, today destabilized in its eastern par
, will very q
ickly become  an important part
of the solutions to the major challenges currently
facing the world
indeed the congo basin
and its large forest massif will
contribute to the fight against
global warming a
theme dear to my esteemed colleague
counterpart emmanuel macron here present
these arable lands well exploited can
reduce twice the
world food deficit these fresh waters
representing 53% in africa and yet 13%
in the world are
potentially energetic its
energy forgiveness potential estimated at 100 thousand
megawatts including 44 thousand for the
inga site alone its soil very rich in
strategic minerals  are
all assets to contribute to peace
and stability  é of the world
ladies and gentlemen i can
reassure you that the democratic republic
of the congo will respond present gold is at the
rendezvous of giving and receiving
with regard to peace and
sustainable development in the world
thank you
gentlemen emmanuel macron near president
of  the republic we have a blurred text
gentlemen emmanuel macron president of
the french republic will now
speak thank you very much
ladies gentlemen heads of state of
government ladies gentlemen
leaders of
international organizations regional organizations
ladies gentlemen vice presidents
vice premier  minister minister
leaders of non-governmental organizations
of corporate foundations elected here present and and
I am probably forgetting some thank you
for being here for this second edition
of the paris forum for peace so
maybe it is  the hardest edition
I tell us collectively because
the first edition there was beautiful
crowd since it was the centenary
of the armistice so we had managed to
catch
more than 60 heads of state of government
and there were if I may say the
charms of the unknown the second edition
is at the bottom  was starting to become a
stable date and there may be
the risks of habit and so your
presence here your commitment as
much as you are is a
reality check for us is proof that
it is taking but  that
we also need to build something
lasting, that is to say useful, and so I
really wanted to thank you for
your presence, your mobilization, but
also to say how much I am convinced that
this Paris forum for peace is
what we  are doing
collectively to a very
profound use
I would say that the first of its
uses is what we have
just heard of having an
Indian activist then the elected President of the
European Commission the Chinese Vice-President
the Pre  sident of the
democratic republic of the congo there are
few places where these data with the same
force and where this sequence can
take on as much meaning and it is
illustrative of this approach, that is to
say 2
those by whom what by which our world
today is done and what makes
it possible to unravel if we do
not put all these energies around the
table on a common project a common agenda
then you said it the lady the
president yesterday without a  year we celebrated
peace at the end of the first
world war not only in france in
all of europe
many here had their country sometimes
that it does not try from the ashes of this
war the whole world was concerned
and europe
think of  that time never again there
is a lesson to be learned among
many others who are happy about this
period is that we failed to
build lasting peace because
we failed to emerge from this first
world conflict found  the good ones
ways of multilateral cooperation
it was the first attempt at the league of nations
and we did not succeed
when no one
reasonably thought that less than 20 years
later new
forms of brutality would begin than 20 years later
an even more terrible war  new
world war was going to
tear europe and the world apart again and thirty
years ago almost to the day
you said it the berlin wall was falling and with
it divisions of europe
sometimes betrayals resentments and we
all thought then  it's great
freedom fighter not only in
germany but everywhere in
eastern europe who had sometimes prepared this
moment had drawn a kind of
unstoppable force we were going to experience a
new teleology of our
international system everywhere democracy
was going to spread everywhere  happiness
go kiss us and basically everywhere
coat some talk about the end of
the story was going to be revealed  iller and there
too we missed his predictions
this time unfortunately also
since if there was a happy time of
our European continent which followed the
last years showed us
how new heartbreaks of new
contemporary fractures you can
put an end to what  was then perceived
as an unstoppable prospect I
take these two examples and these two
anniversaries
because we are almost
in line with his legacies to
say that there is no evidence in the
matter we are talking about and even if
contemporary times can seem
difficult
it is sometimes in difficult times that
we build useful solutions and
I took two happy moments to
say that the predictions of then were
then thwarted by our own
weaknesses, our paralysis or our own
mistakes so there's a lot to look forward
to when we find ourselves because
it's obscured by fractures
deep  e and by a lot of pessimism
and therefore that is why I believe very
deeply in this forum of paris we ap
because we live and the three
interventions which opened our
forum have shown it I believe an unprecedented crisis
of our international system
unprecedented because it does
not come for the first time at the end of a
world war but it is linked
I will say it to profoundly
new challenges and to an endogenous crisis of our
system
the two together it is a  reunion in
a way a unique chemical reaction
let me explain we have a crisis of
our world political and economic
system this system which basically the
social market economy
the opening free trade
cooperation systems thinking after the
second world war  has been
tremendously effective for 70 years
it has lifted hundreds of millions of
people out of poverty
you have reminded us of this, particularly in
your country Mr. Vice President  it
has made it possible to pacify a huge
region thought that the war or the
conflict was unstoppable
it has made possible an unprecedented system of balance control
but these last years have shown
it it has caused new inequalities to re-emerge
sometimes in our societies it has fractured
contemporary societies
also giving rise to a crisis in our
democracies with a doubt in all
Western democracies, which
was its mainstay, it has caused
unilateralism to be reborn, sometimes even among those
who were the guarantors in the last
resort of this international system and
therefore we have  if I can say an
endogenous crisis of the system which is that
on the political economic level
this system is today in crisis is
jostled and at the same time
problems have emerged for
ten years that are profoundly new, in any
case with this force
the  demographic problem and
only one of its consequences which is the
phenomenon of the great migrations from which
we live.  go and we sometimes only deal
with the consequences but which is
much broader much
deeper how to feed a planet which
does not stop growing how to manage the
demographic imbalances of which I
recall it besides the main
migratory forces are played out within
the  Africa itself sometimes within the
Asian continent also with
major disruptions
the technological and digital challenge and
all that prevail 2 transformations
of work but also of our imaginations
of the interrelationships of our countries and the
climate challenge mainly the  fight
against global warming and the fight
for biodiversity
these three great challenges I am
probably not exhaustive but these three
great challenges added to the challenge which is
not new to it but which continues to be
a fight for the fight for freedoms
and  Democracy Demo therefore comes
at a time of fracture of the
international system and of our own societies
when to respond  To take up this challenge,
we need more cooperation and
therefore the risk that is collectively
ours is that the temptation will re-emerge
in our countries
all those who have spoken all those
who are present here be at the bottom of
laziness first risk  say to each other we have
organizations we like them do
n't the questions haven't they have
sometimes lost their purpose
no one understands anymore and let's raise but
hide this breast that we can't voice
as we say in molière and it
will go better I don't  I don't think at all
I showed them sometimes in their
time maybe some in this room
a few days or a few
weeks ago I think we need the
truth prudishness or hypocrisy
it doesn't work in the
why because our
fellow citizens see it we are in an
open world
the experts who are present here the
citizens the activists see the
consequences of this world there when it no
longer works he tells us
so hypocrisy and silence is not a
solution and intellectual laziness
or action is not a solution either
second option at least as risky
is non-cooperation,
that is to say the return to
unilateralism or a form of 10
pairs regionalism I believe that this
option is also very risky
it tempts some what we can say
it is much more effective to fall
back to respond either even to the own
challenge to provide a solution
closure because the evil in a
way would be linked to a world that has become too
open I don't believe it either we have
tested this option in the past it
produces war nationalism it
's war
when they forget you reminded us of this
distinguo crimping thanks you for it the
difference that there is between nationalism
and patriotism and the non-cooperation
of deconstruct is in a way
that we have at least succeeded in building
during these last decades and it
can lead to a  third risk which
would be a possible path
hegemony basically we could say to
ourselves in the face of these crises there have to be
new powers which emerge will
get behind it it would be a
solution to say there are some some
great powers they  are going to settle the
subject for the others and we accept in
a way to put ourselves behind I
believe that hegemony and I say it from a
country which sometimes tried this way for
the others it was the colonial moment
of the republic  French we
held this speech russia including in the name
of freedom by saying we are going to
solve the world's problems for
you we are enlightened we are going to enlighten the
others it will work better it lasts a
while it does not work very long it doesn't
is no longer possible in the world
and therefore the path of hegemony or
distribution among a few
hegemonic powers is also not
desirable because it will
again produce resentment again
frustration at  new from the d2
the humiliation of Geneva to meet
these challenges that one of the most
difficult and most complex paths is
that of balanced cooperation
that which is called multilateralism,
that is to say that they accept the
discussions  disagreements
the mediations to find
common solutions and for me the
dialogue which has between the first three
interventions that we have had and which will
take place for two days between the
different continents the different
actors is in this respect deeply
essential the europe of  First of all is a
continent where the solution must be
built
Madam President I thank you for being
there in a busy agenda and for
having strongly supported this vision of a
geopolitical Europe as you have I
indeed believe very deeply that
europe has part of the answer to the
solution for a simple reason
our europe we are several here to
participate actively and that good evening
members of the european union then
geographical sense  phic of this europe
we all have this role europe is a
laboratory of multilateralism
perhaps the
most complex laboratory because it has been
exhausted for millennia by
civil wars
therefore europe is undoubtedly the  place
in the world where we know best the price
of cooperation or rather the price of
non-cooperation and therefore the treasure that is
the ability to build balances
including when or would push
this geopolitical europe
to be different, it must be sovereign  democratic
but in fact build the solutions
of new balances and I think to be
this kind of two thirds of confidence
between the united states of america and
china if you allow me sir
the vice president which supposes that she
and her voice d  Savoie independence
and that they help to build
useful solutions, as you
reminded us, as you committed to it for a
moment
Madam President and I think that
it is formed  I am
sure that we continue to be its
partners in international forums
and actors in the
construction of these new solutions
in a Europe thus redesigned with all
our regional partners and I think
that Europe has this vocation of aggregating
around it the powers  of
goodwill and in this respect the initiative
of an alliance for multilateralism
pushed by the ministers of foreign affairs
here present and I
thank them for it
is an initiative which was started on the
sidelines of the united nations summit which
will be continued by the  ministers mass
the drian with their colleagues and which is
I think a very important initiative
which is emblematic of what precisely
this europe can bring in the
concert of nations alongside the
european commission then there
is asia as you said  mr vice
president many heads of state and
government are also there who come
from central asia or india or other
countries  s from asia to today tremendous
dfid of stability peace of
construction there too
new solutions of clarification sometimes of
border conflict of
demographic and religious challenges it is a
laboratory
it has often been in recent
years a laboratory of conflicts which
then have always affected europe
and asia and in this continuity with our
own challenges I repeat it here with
great force and to say all
the commitment that is ours in
some of the conflicts that
still divides it but asia  you said is
now stabilizing
the initiatives you have taken
is part of the
connectivity initiatives of the european union is
a useful complement and a voice of this
dialogue also with china and the
China's role, as you
recalled, is an important element of
this stabilization and I thank you,
Mr. Vice President, for having had
very strong words in this regard, I believe  is
that role in particular on the
climate challenge that you will have brought and
what you have started to decline is
very important and in terms of the fight
against global warming as
in the fight
for biodiversity the way the role
that asia will be able to  building is an
extremely structuring element in this
respect 2020 includes several meetings
that of a Sino-European dialogue where the
fight against global warming
as the economic subject will be decisive
that also of the cop15 biodiversity which
will be held in china is a meeting
essential for the international order
and then there is africa dear president
if these credits which you spoke
admirably by a not only of
your country but of the conflicts many
presidents are here present and have
also taken on their time even
though  'they bravely lead
countries that are rocked by
terrorism and by groups that
challenge national sovereignty  the who
threaten not only the stability of
their country of an entire continent but
also ours and here too we have a
linked destiny and I believe that Africa
as I recalled it last night with
some of you is
today  living with us
collectively a challenge it has long
been an object of multilateralism
it is becoming one of the
subjects of multilateralism, that is to say
that it plays an active part in it and I
want to salute the commitment of the states
Africans present here and more broadly
African countries which are taking their
destiny into their own hands are building
concrete solutions
Tunisia was able to do so with
great courage when it came to
rebuilding democracy several years ago
I salute the presence here  of the Prime
Minister who with great force
alongside the late Egyptian President had
to lead the destinies of the country after
this democratic miracle, but the whole
African continent and I am thinking in
particular of the s  ahel today has this
challenge and the strength of African countries to
take up the political challenge, also
military and security, is essential
and we have in this new international order
to also build new solutions
within the framework of the united nations
allowing us to support better than  we are
doing today
this security capacity of Africa
but also to help it to build in terms
of education, health,
environment and economy
those which are the four solutions which
make it possible to  to build lasting peace and
to prevent
the destabilizing factors from appearing in the universities in this
triptych and I obviously do not forget
and I will come back to this in a moment the
other regions that I have mentioned less
but in this dialogue  that you have
started with us and there is the beginning of a
solution of a common agenda of
new partnerships that we can
forge and I believe that in our
ability to build contemporary solutions
there is obviously  t the
dialogue with the United States of America
and the American countries, of which I hope
that in the third edition we will
succeed in mobilizing the latter more
to contribute even more to
this dialogue, but there is the ability to
build ways and means of
new cooperation  we have
speakers they are sometimes blocked
the united nations is part of it it is
our responsibility to continue to
move forward to better share a
common agenda and so for me I will conclude on
this point the value-added strength of this
forum of our work of  the reflection is
in progress
it is to know how to rebuild forums
new ways of cooperation
new d new alliance between our
international organizations as
we knew how to do it in the fight against
the inequalities
a few weeks ago in biarritz between
the international organizations and the
different countries between governments
international organizations
ngos foundations actors  academics and
companies and basically through these
two-day exchanges but through the work
throughout the year that we
have a shared agenda, that of the
fight against discrimination
and access to the law,
that precisely of the construction of
new  balances and
new rights in digital matters
that of the fight against
global warming and for
biodiversity
that of a sustainable structure to
deal with migratory issues that also
of the fight against geographical imbalances
and the resolution of
conflicts
many are affected here but j  I hope
that, apart from our discussions, we
will be able to help advance several
sensitive subjects,
that is our common agenda if it is
shared by all the actors here
present have already done useful work
and then it is the construction of
new forms of cooperation of
lee will do idji alliances for example
supported by our companies to fight
against inequalities l  he partnership
for information and democracy
led by reporters without borders is
supported by several
elected governments companies to fight against
disinformation and for better
cooperation the christchurch call
between governments of companies
to fight against terrorist content
and allow d  acting more
effectively here are some examples
of concrete innovations where actors
who did not speak to each other until then
decide to act together
this forum will be full of
new initiatives we must continue in motion
to somehow not
compete with the forums of
multilateralism  contemporary but
to help reinvent them to
complete them and above all to act usefully
why unilateralism is rising in
certain countries why doubt is re-emerging
because what our citizens
reproach us for is sometimes our
inefficiency our desire not to
see or  to act insufficiently quickly
and I believe that the co  nstructing these
useful solutions its
new alliances its innovations is an
extremely important element of the
collective response to our
contemporary challenges in our countries is a
way of combining this cooperation
which I explained a moment ago I
will conclude by quoting the late  agnes
et l'air is a great activist
like you trisha de la liberté she
was over 90
she was a hungarian intellectual
and every day she went swimming
in the great lakes of hungary and in
july fashions she did not return
from  'one of those swims because
the spirit of revolt and indignation
preserves for a long time and continue to
give courage and anja seiler who was a
wonderful woman had this sentence
saying that our time needs more
than others a  form of heroism
which sets itself the task of grasping what
the present is the task remains 10 is it
to make oneself available to what helps us
well
this availability  to those who
help us comes and this heroism name speaks
agnès and the air if this ability to
understand the world as it comes to
us to think about it and try to provide
useful answers nor the cowardice of
not seeing or of  to stay in our habits
neither the cowardice of not doing nor the
comfort of being far from the daily life of our
fellow citizens
what we are talking about here these two wars
of conflicts of imbalance it is from the
daily life our fellow citizens it is up to us to
settle it we have received  mandate for that
to us to continue to act usefully and
that is why I believe very
deeply in the usefulness of this forum of
paris for peace and that I thank the
president and the director
general all the organizers but
also  all the contributors
and that I thank you very
deeply for your presence
today in Paris thank you to you
[Applause]
ladies and john legend
ladies and gentlemen in order
to immortalize this moment we are going to
take the photo  official
tography of the paris peace forum
please stadium we thank you for getting
up at 6:30 a.m. china
and this year time bidding please
put on your seat what you want what
you may have in your hands as well
as your translation equipment  if
necessary or case english look app
world life brad spence angel from syria
wants to raise your head there and direct
your gaze towards the point of light which
is high up in the center of the stage
free to one
please bright's hood paul le guen
please direct  again your gaze
towards the luminous point 3 2 1
5th thank you